control freak she wasn't me
every night she's like this I can't
fault never cease dedication but I can't
see a problem she's sending out dishes
as soon as they're ready rather than
insurance everyone on the table is
spread together
where's the squid who else kitchen I
know because we had to ask mrs. Eddie's
on it but I've clocked another lady
waiting for her turbot
that last may cause half of the five
eighties
this thought of issue could ruin a whole
tables dining experience and Sam knows
it course on Table nine coming I think
what they should serve all the food
together and I didn't want my friends
food getting cold while I was waiting
for mine so a little bit me no one
don't make me to never is determined not
to let a little slip-up like this ruin
her service within minutes two hot
dishes are winging their way out to the
dining room i watch their work 21 okay
sorry about that
and just to make sure there's no hard
feelings Sam is on the charm offensive
let me show you how you fill it the
talent we do know your way around more
or less I'm very happy to do it some
people like to fiddle around to do it
themselves
others prefer a fitted nicely done it's
meaty but it's a very light flavor
there's a lot of vinegar and olive oil
that I put with it as they do in Spain
and it doesn't overpower the fish it's
really really lovely second course Star
Wars token increase yeah yes all the
stuff is gone I mean the pledge I want
to see one two three four five six seven
eight
target okay eight hundred as well as the
delicious turbot
for the main course Nevers is serving a
speciality roast suckling pig math
watering Li sweet and tender smells
[ __ ] amazing
if another Spanish showstopper the
suckling pigs fantastic full of flavor
really well cooked the simple potatoes
that it comes on a really exquisite the
whole thing just melts in your mouth the
more important it's not a really nice
fragrant sort of well time
really this could well be the best food
I've seen so far in this competition
along I'm here
how many more main course we've got to
go that's it that's it yeah oh God
service is almost over but with the
combination of delicious desserts and
seminaries unfaltering charm the dyeing
room is still buzzing our mother grew up
in the Yorker but she's actually half
Scottish half Bulgarian so we sort of
look Spanish but aren't at all this was
beautifully cooked
I had it sober I couldn't fault it was
beautiful
food is fantastic today absolutely
brilliant limit on flavor I'm very very
close thank you very much
right okay what can I pick on what can I
say that we have to improve on here
there was a moment in service tonight
service gets all good and that was just
after the start of the gun that's the
only awkward moment I saw the food's
amazing you can smile now yeah yeah no
no you don't do after we yeah now yes
the service tonight you two just raise
the bar good job